Well,
I think there are lots of things that
that can be taught.
So,
um,
you know,
the ultimate that it's a very good
question.
Uh,
but it,
what is true is that in the world of
business,
fairly quickly,
people find themselves in a leadership
position in the sense that they're
responsible for a group or they're
responsible for a team.
And for,
for managing that team,
motivating at getting people to follow a
path to achieve some common objectives.
So there are techniques that you can
teach that help people to better
understand what's involved and,
and motivating teams and groups of
people.
And I think it's,
you know,
it's an ongoing process,
but there,
there are lots of people who believe
that leadership can be taught.
Um,
and,
uh,
lots of corporations that take it very
seriously.
Corporations like General Electric,
which have,
you know,
made a reputation for,
for developing business leaders.
Yeah.
Well,
I think,
uh,
how to function.
Getting people to understand better,
how to function in teams,
how to work together.
Um,
how to set goals,
how to organize activities in ways that
lead you to achieve the common,
the common objectives of the team.